[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Sean Salisbury former NFL
quarterback host of the Sean Salisbury
show Sports Talk 790 in Houston just
celebrated his 60th birthday happy
birthday Sean
thank you tough sledding by throwing
that 60 on me Daddy and I had the under
with you you know did you really yeah
well look see the money maker right here
Daniel
40-ish 45 now I've got it it's just
another year man just another year and I
had my German chocolate cake with
chocolate icing is what is my go-to cake
there you go could you throw the ball 50
yards right now yeah could you throw it
60.
uh probably give me about a week to warm
up and get going probably in this little
over 60 now yeah
it may not land in the ocean if I'm
standing in a boat but I can I you know
remember when they did punt pass and
kicked in yeah you know when they put
the line out there and he'd throw it
he's got they measured how far and then
how far off the line now mine may go out
there farther than Andy Reeds when he
was doing it but it might end up in the
18th row to somebody's mom so yeah I
could still throw it I just can't move
it it you know when I look back on that
video with Andy Reid as to what a 13
year old and it almost feels like it's a
Saturday Night Live skit where yep you
have somebody who's three it'd be like
Chris Farley going out there with kids
who were you know five years old and has
Andy talked about that
I don't I don't know if any I've never
seen like a national interview where
it's like dude can you walk us through
your passing kick preparation you know
what really what it got us man doesn't
he look like you know like Lou the toe
grows Andy only had to kick straight on
right Square toed right with his tennis
shoe yeah can you imagine if he'd really
shocked the world and step back and then
went soccer style Autumn like Pete Rose
I like that uh the Texans aren't on the
clock we've been focusing on the Chicago
Bears up top but I know that came out
yesterday or day before maybe the Texans
are interested in Jimmy Garoppolo which
might sound like tampering before you're
allowed to Tamper but uh the Texans
gonna take whatever quarterback the
Bears or that person who uh or team that
goes up top they take number one yeah
Dana yeah Dan I think it's below you
know on a scale of one to ten in that
four or five range or lower that the
Texans trade up I think they believe
that if Bryce Young is gone that CJ
Stroud can be a player and he listen I
love potential but I like production
first Dan and when you talk about risk
reward or your risk tolerance or the if
Bryce Young's got the least amount of
ifs in his game you and I have discussed
this the past I don't like ifs around
guys I'm going to take that high if a
guy's accurate if he lives up to the
hype the only if for Bryce young is well
can he hand the can of can he handle the
hits well we'll see can anybody handle
the hits so if they're in the two hole
which I think they'll stay there in my
opinion I think they believe CJ Stroud
will be a player but I do not believe
that that takes them out of the Jimmy
Garoppolo sweepstakes that's familiarity
they know how to coach the first second
third Stringer Jimmy could be on a
walk-in and start and I think it'd be an
ideal situation I think there's not only
mutual interest if the price is right I
think you're going to see Garoppolo and
I do think you're going to see a
quarterback drafted with a number two
pick because Stroud can play as well
how much optimism would you have if
you're a Jets fan right now
are you are we including Aaron Rodgers
or not well that's part of the optimism
if you believe in it uh so how much
optimism would you have that he's going
to that they're going to get this done
uh a lot I think it's stale in Green Bay
and as much as I love Aaron Rodgers and
I do and I think he's a fantastic player
I think he'll play great football if
he's a jet or somewhere else and I think
the Jets need to find out about Jordan
love and I think the leadership I think
there comes a point in time when you say
is the headache worth the talent and I
think with all that's gone on the
headache isn't anymore for Green Bay but
they'll welcome the migraine if it is
that or a slight headache in New York
listen when's the last time Dan they had
that guy at quarterback they thought
Zach Wilson but when you got a guy who's
a Hall of Famer could win an MVP still
and takes a team that was on the cusp
last year of getting to that spot and
take him over the Over the Top This
should be the most optimism Jets fans
have had in a long time because they'll
have the best quarterback of the most
publicized quarterback since what Joe
Willie Namath farv was there but farv
wasn't as good at Rogers at this stage
when he got to the Jets I think they
should have great optimism especially in
that division that's loaded with skill
setting quarterbacks that can play their
ass off but this is what I don't
understand if you're Aaron Rodgers
you're going to get paid wherever you go
now it's about winning a second Super
Bowl does he have a better chance
winning that in the AFC with the Jets or
in a watered-down NFC by staying with
the Packers
far more in the NFC if the Dan think
about this the Packers really don't have
to approve anything through Aaron right
you don't have no trade calls they can
ship him wherever he wants wherever they
want to go and you're asking the Packers
okay when are we going to find out about
Jordan love Aaron obviously gives us a
better chance to win he's Aaron Rodgers
but the NFC outside of Philadelphia and
a healthy quarterback in San Francisco
who's a dominant threat there there
really isn't one those are the two you
start with we keep talking about the
Cowboys and other teams the AFC The
Gauntlet you've got to go through yeah
think about this if Aaron Rodgers goes
to the jet stand he's just the Finish is
like fourth or fifth in the AFC
quarterback slate depending on where the
other Herbert's and Allen's and if Lamar
gets it Joe burrow Patrick moms they're
loaded so that is a very difficult place
to go easier path in the NFC but if
you're Green Bay Dan do you want to do
this again do you want to push this off
again and if the headache is too big and
you say leadership the way the players
in the building are reacting it may be
time to go and if you're Aaron Rodgers
and you like a challenge you'll get one
in New York and if you go two games and
throw a couple picks you'll hear about
it too so but for the Jets it's a must
do if you can pull it off
help me understand this I know the
Ravens what they're doing with Lamar and
the question is does somebody want to go
in and give them for two first round
picks and then pay him whatever that
money is that he's going to want
but if you're the Bengals and you're the
Chargers
Joe burrow and Justin Herbert are they
asking for 230 million dollars
guaranteed are they asking for DeSean
Watson money and do those franchise
franchises give that money to those two
quarterbacks I think they're going to
ask for a lot more than that Dan when
Burl and Herbert's time come I do we're
looking at that's going to get up to
even we're already in rarified air but
guaranteed money is the new thing right
that's exactly right you're right Dan 50
million a year and guarantee five years
or whatever 250 million guarantee at all
that's the Cleveland Browns opened up
that Pandora's Box and now the rest of
the world if you keep giving it you're
going to have to keep paying it because
no matter what Lamar gets you damn well
know because it's just the way it works
in sports did Joe burrow and Herbert are
not only going to ask for but if you
gave it to Lamar too they're going to
get it now I'm gonna backtrack I mean
back up here for a second I think the
Ravens are absolutely out of their mind
if they don't do what they can to sign
Lamar Jackson I would he's worth two
first-round picks but I wouldn't be
willing those guys are hard to find and
now you bring what I think is one of the
five best coordinators in sports right
now in Todd monk in there I think it's a
beautiful match but I get the resistance
to say here's 250 guaranteed million but
but I think he's had a better start to
his career than DeSean Watson the
question is is Baltimore willing to
mortgage their franchise and risk a guy
who's high risk on the edge running it
has been banged up but brings you such
Dynamic play making if he was in this
draft you'd pick him first knowing what
his what his skill level is and what
he's done in the NFL that's where you
take him so with that in mind if I'm the
Ravens I'm not letting him go but I'm
still not also paying a hundred percent
guarantee I'll get close but he's not
getting 100 guarantee that's the
Cleveland Browns fault doesn't mean I
have to do it all right but if Justin
Herbert Joe burrow and Lamar Jackson are
in this year's draft
you just just for the simple Pier Dan
you know this we build from inside out
from the quarterback position too we
want the guy who can deliver it from the
hula hoop in the pocket and then expand
him and he can buy time and all three of
them can but the level of Pat It Go
burrow and the you could have the
argument with Lamar or Herbert but I
think because the Purity and the the
physical specimen and the size and
knowing the injury history right now
you'd probably put Herbert second all
three of them are deserving I would pay
Lamar Jackson and keep him in Baltimore
because you're just not going to wake up
fall out of bed and land on another
Lamar Jackson Joe burrow and Herbert are
also going to get paid when that
conversation takes place talking to Sean
Salisbury host of the Sean Salisbury
show Sports Talk 790 in Houston obj is
working out for teams today
and I know that he narrowed it down to
the Giants Cowboys and bills
this just seems like a foregone
conclusion that Jerry Jones is going to
bring him in right I mean it's about
yeah
yeah it is Dan he loves star power and
quite frankly Dan think about that
franchise CD lamb really good player but
they still are looking for another home
run hitter dominant player and I don't
know how many times we're going to keep
making excuses for the Cowboys offense
and Dak Prescott but you keep loading
them up and they keep doing it you can't
get beat in the first round of the
playoffs or get curb stopped in the
second round so
um I I think it seems star power it
seems like a natural fit and they've got
good players it'd be a good place for
him to go but you know where he's going
to go Dan where the money's the best and
the opportunity presents itself with
Odell Beckham yeah I I as much as I
would go to Buffalo because I got a
better chance of being no doubt you know
a Super Bowl Contender the Giants you
know that might be a mirage you know
maybe they're going to be a formidable
team but I I would stay in Dallas he
wants to go to Dallas you get to play in
indoors your America's team you get
you're on uh you know National TV I mean
all those things have to factor in in
for obj here I don't want to go to that
weather in Buffalo plus Stefan Diggs is
the number one guy there and even though
CD Lam is great yep because he's already
shown that he could blend in with Cooper
cup with the Rams and be a complimentary
figure there that feels like it's Dallas
and Dan no doubt about it plus with this
experience if he's fully healthy and
running like we know he can or close
I'm not so sure that he's not the number
one there who knows so it's six and one
half doesn't it I'm talking about CD
lamb in Dallas so there's still another
level to his game and and more weapons
more opportunity and like you said
better weather and a clearer path to get
to the postseason in the NFC than the
AFC Dan can I ask you one question yes
if your career was on the line
with these four quarterbacks in this
draft I gave you 30 days to get ready
for a game and your career was on the
line
and they all have the same Talent which
quarterback are you taking first
is this is one game
one game and I gotta win it for you to
save your career as a coach and you get
30 days to prepare which one of these
four drafted of the big four are you
taking I'd take Bryce Sean
yeah Dan there's and you know what the
risk reward but also think about the
there is when you talk about the things
that guys don't have tell me he's got
everything you want production there's
potential he's a playmaker High football
IQ not saying the others don't but the
safest pick even though he's the
smallest has got to be Bryce Young on
production and the way people talk about
him it's amazing at 195 pounds he's not
supposed to be an IT guy but now at 204
pounds all of a sudden well Dan we
gained nine pounds well if that's if
size matters when it comes to the size
of a quarterback I'd be wearing a I'd
have a Hall of Fame jacket behind you in
your studio so there you go so I'm just
anxious to see how the combine works
over into people's oh my gosh Factor
after what we saw good to talk to you
again happy birthday have a good weekend
thank you buddy you two always great to
talk to you buddy Sean Salisbury
uh host of the Sean Salisbury show
Sports Talk 790 in Houston